il n'est même j'avais perdu
françois legault a annoncé une aide
bonifiés pour le sinistre y 40 dollars
par jour au lieu de 20 pour les dépenses
quotidiennes et au remboursement maximal
de 385 milles dollars pour les maisons
qui ne pourront être préservés le coût
des matériaux de construction augmente
et des coupes construire a augmenté donc
on parle d'une valeur de reconstruction
et on voit aussi
rembourser la valeur de remplacement des
meubles montre
et sert thibault et monique gens
vivaient dans une maison avec une vue
imprenable
le glissement de terrain est survenu à
quelques mètres de chez elle il était
très très bien en aval comme
l'impression d'avoir gagné à loto québec
c'est une partie une retraite qui est
non alors moi j'ai travaillé mais pas si
lointain pour mieux garantir
un bien être je t'en parle depuis ça
fait des bouillons ici
elles font partie des quatre familles
qui viennent d'apprendre que leur maison
ne pourra pas être sauvée d'un autre âge
dont pas ça toujours d'affaires ce qu'on
a vécu l'eau puis c'est moi je pourrais
vie mes enfants à lomé en fait
mais toutes nos amis sont alentours
c'est notre force
d'autres vivent près du trou béant n'ont
toujours pas leur juste si leurs
résidences sont jugés sécuritaires il
n'y aura pas d'indemnités pour une
nouvelle construction roxane des chaînes
et son conjoint cherche tout de même
nouveau domicile non ça me tente pas que
dans 10 ans 15 ans même s'ils me
sécurise en zinc et repose dans j ch
inconsciemment je veux qu dangereux
des tranches de sol de 5 à 15 mètres
tout autour de la zone touchée pourrait
tomber à tout moment la solution adoucir
la pente on va excavés partout sur le
pourtour de la cicatrice de glissements
ici mais on va partir d'un endroit qui
plus beau on va faire enlever tout un
immense tranche de sol en s'approchant
progressivement de la cicatrice du
glissement pour que à chaque fois que
les pelles mécaniques et les
travailleurs progresse et qu'ils soient
toujours en sécurité les ingénieurs du
ministère des transports ont voulu faire
preuve de grande prudence en
recommandant l'évacuation d'autant de
familles sur 79 maisons évacuées au
moins 67 pourront être réintégré mais
cela pourrait prendre plusieurs mois ici
marc isabel rochât radio canada saguenay